kamala harris wants you to know her
job's really hard the vp is doing damage
control after being called a bully and a
terrible to work for person by her own
staff harris dismissing allegations
she's a bad boss and claims she will not
be distracted by ridiculous headlines
harris adding this quote there's nothing
about this job that is supposed to be
easy if something is coming to me it's
because it needs to be addressed and
because by definition it's not going to
be easy if it was easy it would have
been handled before it comes to me
she plagiarized that from someone sounds
like catcher in the rye
i don't know i've heard that before but
it is comedy gold the reason i suck at
my job is that the job is hard and the
uh they only hand me the difficult tasks
right like sitting and talking okay yeah
she's like john wick or something we
need to call you in at the last minute
they hand her all the problems and then
she fails i'm done here that was tough
you only get the toughest job right
only the toughest
the only talent she apparently has is
making something that should be very
easy look extremely difficult
and tough
she's supposed to interact with child
actors who are paid to suck up to her
who are paid to make her look good i
mean like mayor pete and yeah yeah yes
i shop in the little boys section
um and she can't even make that work she
is purely talentless it's like
everything she does even the cleanup
interviews there's something funny there
for me yeah yeah look
look it is hard and i think she's
learning the rhythms of the job there's
criticism that's warranted of her but i
give her some credit today in the last
day or so as she was able to announce
some big investments at least part of
kind of an alliance for prosperity
lookalike that's what kennedy did for
the for for the for for latin and uh for
south america particularly in our own
region this hemisphere she announced
about a billion to two billion dollars
worth of activity and investments i
think they need to build on that so
she's understanding starting to
understand even better this role and
what i'm happy is that she's not
complaining she's complaining that hey
people want to criticize me maybe i
should handle the curtis a little bit
differently but she's welcoming the
challenge she does that she'll be in a
better position imagine dick cheney
during the war on terror dana
it's hard stuff you know they but they
they only get me the big stuff yeah it
was easy yeah but it was nice
one thing i really loved is that she
trashed the media coverage that she's
getting during an interview that was a
profile piece that was set up for her to
talk about how she had redecorated the
vice president's office
so oh she didn't like how pence did it
that's like a probably not i mentioned i
think she has good style i'll tell you
that not better than myself
and
taste is exquisite yes so some of the
some of the news rags in dc are
crowdsourcing ideas from political
pundits of all stripes saying what do
you think she should do
and i just can't belie i would be so
embarrassed if that was happening and
this is what i would say they didn't
come to me for advice so i just give it
for free on here um
for her situation right now and the only
way to get out of it is to show not tell
so show what you're doing don't tell us
how hard your job is that the media
coverage is unfair just show you're
doing a good job and the good media will
follow show-and-tell
show not tell
how do you not know that
i'm not john wick what can i say greg
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis